>>The canonical example of
classification is predicting this species
of iris flower based on
the numerical measurements of its sepals and petals.
But what if rather than its measurements,
we want to train a machine learning model to predict
an iris species based on a photograph of the flower?
Well, an image is just a matrix of numerical values.
So we could flatten the matrix for
each of these images into a vector.
Of course, we'll start with data for
which we already have some ground truth.
So we know the class of iris to which each image belongs.
When we do this for all of our image,
and we end up with an array of
vectors containing pixel values that represent
the features of our images and an array
of integer values that represent the class labels.
These then are the x and y values for our model.
Next, we will split these arrays to create
a subset for training and hold back a subset for validation.
Then we're ready to go and train and validate our model.
When we're happy with the model,
we can take a new image.
We can extract the pixel value features,
and we can submit them to the model to
predict the species of the iris in the picture.